okay we're in live chair thank you
thank you good morning everybody to this
latest meeting of the trafford
republican government 19 public
engagement board
thank you all for your attendance i have
apologies received today from rebecca
domain are there any further apologies
at all oh and also um kirsty johnson are
there any other further apologies
right i don't see any thank you
no no no i apologize thank you very much
indeed are there any decorations of
interest in today's agenda items
i don't see any thank you minutes of the
last meeting please commentate these as
read and a true and accurate record
thank you uh before i pass on to helen
collins um i'm sure helen's going to
give us a very full update
i would like to say that i think we've
been in traffic on a bit of a helter
skelter ride since the last meeting in
terms of infection rates
but
and certainly press interest in
following our last meeting uh certainly
the manchester union news covered us on
the saturday
and that resulted in radio interviews
for helen and me and tv appearances
i'm pleased to say obviously our rates
are beginning to fall as was predicted
and i'm more pleased to see that it's
now
uh back in the national headlines
concerns about rising infection rates
right across the country
um i'd like to thank helen for the
report that's been prepared and
circulated to members today i think that
gives us a very clear picture of all the
activity that's been going on in traffic
for which i am very grateful i'll pass
over to you hannah i'm sure you've got a
lot to tell us about schools and
all sorts of different uh things that
have been going on thank you
helen we can't hear you
can you hear me now yes we can oh sorry
so yeah so it's um an incredibly busy
week last week but i just wanted to
thank all our team and everybody
involved in covid response across
trafford for pulling together because
there's been some phenomenal work that's
been ongoing
so just to um
share with you that our rates are
declining which is really good because
we had we did peak at a rate of eight
four six last week and that's per
hundred thousand um
and that was the number of uh two over
two thousand cases in trafford people
who tested positive but this week um up
to the 15th of october because there's
always a four day time lag um our rates
are now at six five six so you can see
we've really kind of um come down nearly
200 per hundred thousand within seven
days which is really reassuring however
it's really important for us to
recognize that um we're still the
highest in greater manchester and this
is still a very high case rate for us in
trafford so we just really need to be
mindful that although we're not
nationally number one we are still you
know have high rates of covert
so um that's where our rates look at the
moment our our rates are still the
highest in our zero to 14 year old age
group but that's starting to steady down
now and it's coming down quite um
quickly within that age group the area
of concern for us is and has always been
our older population so for our 60
pluses i think when we met last time we
hadn't seen any kind of increase within
our 60 plus age group but we have seen
that so we're now at a rate of 257 per
100 000 in our 60 uh plus age group so
i'll talk to you about some of the
measures we brought in around that
group but it is looking to stabilize in
that group but it's still high so
thinking about going into the winter we
just need to be aware really
uh positivity so this is the number of
people the proportion of people who go
for a test who then test positive has
decreased as well which is good news so
that's at 12
uh we're still the highest in greater
manchester and um stockport is second to
us and they are um
lower by a hundred per hundred thousand
so we still got you know quite a quite
um a difference between us and the
second
borough
so in terms of schools catherine will
talk to us more about the contact
tracing outbreak hub but we do have uh
ten outbreaks running in schools at the
moment five in highs and five in primary
schools um the worst affected area
remains the west so david hume is the
ward at the moment with the highest
rates at 929 but all award rates there
again following that pattern and are
declining
um alongside all the other boroughs
a hospitalization number is still a
small number but but we are seeing just
a steady increase so it's a very small
increase but this is something that
we're watching very carefully with our
nhs colleagues
um
and our deaths fortunately remain low um
still so that's good to know
so in terms of um
the activity that came off the back well
we obviously you'll know and you'll have
seen the covid activity report which we
pulled together to demonstrate all the
different work programs that we have
active across uh trafford at the moment
but i just wanted to to note just to
share with you some key kind of actions
that we took last week so you'll be very
aware that our secondary schools at the
moment all our pupils and staff at
secondary schools are currently wearing
face coverings
you know it's a really important
intervention it isn't the the silver
bullet but it's really important in
terms of one of many interventions that
can reduce the risk so if you are
asymptomatic and developing the
infection or symptomatic but just not
aware that you have the infection
wearing a good quality face mask
prevents um or reduces the likelihood of
you spreading that um so schools are in
face coverings primary schools we've
asked adults and primary school settings
to wear face coverings and for parents
picking and
dropping and collecting to wear face
coverings as well because what we're
aware of although the majority of people
will be outside there will be areas of
congestion uh during that pickup so it's
just reducing that risk really
our household contact um
testing is continuing so if you have if
you're a staff member or pupil um and
you're
in key stage two or above if you have
somebody in your household who's tested
positive we have recommended the um ulfd
test for 10 days um just before going
into school and you only go into school
with a negative test um again just to
say that i think it's us and cumbria who
have implemented this when the school
isn't in outbreak because it just feels
the right thing to do it's very
preventative measure
so far all these measures have been
really welcomed by schools the other
element with school is just really
reinforcing um
measures hand hygiene symptom awareness
um and social distancing and ventilation
so we've done that and the letter went
out to all parents and all carers across
trafford uh
at the end of the previous week so and
and i have to say um we haven't
had the volume of complaints that we
would have usually have had so it feels
that like the people of trafford are
supporting the majority people are
supporting the action that we're taking
then um we wrote
uh just asked for support around um
public transport and ayman boyle did
reply with a really supportive message
to say that they will be looking at
different actions that they could take
and my understanding was that there was
an increase in visibility across the
networks at the end of last week um
supporting the wearing of face coverings
and hand sanitizing so that's really
good
for care homes um obviously like i said
previously that's
that age group is the group that we're
most worried about and we do have a
number of outbreaks running in care
homes at the moment and i think it's
important to note that although um you
know it's very much about hospital
admissions for our care homes if we have
an outbreak in a care home um
they they close to
admissions so that means if you're
waiting to be discharged from hospital
it's very difficult for our adult social
care colleagues to to place people so
care home outbreaks are really important
in terms of the running of our larger
system
so we do have i think it's five
outbreaks and care homes at the moment
so we wrote out to all care home
providers last week and requested that
um
that um
they ensured all the ipc measures are in
place our care homes are phenomenal i
have to say they've been absolutely
brilliant all the way through and the
other measure we asked them to put in is
to re request to pause a visit from
visitors who are 16 and under and that
was um just really just thinking about
that school age population and
vaccinated population visiting in care
homes so what we've said is there's a
number of caveats so if it's end of life
um obviously the visit is allowed but to
ensure lfd testing pre-visit
or if the visit can happen outside and
socially distanced than to support that
visit because obviously what we do know
is visiting in care homes is really
important for health and wellbeing but
it's just about really supporting those
care homes at the moment in terms of the
infection
both the measures for schools and for
care homes will be reviewed on the 1st
of november to help us just to have a
look at whether we lift any of those
kind of recommendations or we remain for
a few weeks extra
there's been a huge amount of activity
which our comms colleagues and community
engagement colleagues will talk to you
about in a moment um
so this is just a flavor really of what
i'm sharing with you but the other piece
of work that started last week which is
really exciting actually it shows what a
geek i am in public health terms is
working with our ccg colleagues and what
we've done is identified um
particularly in our more uh deprived
communities in the north of the borough
um
patients who haven't had their vaccine
not because they've declined it because
they're anti-vac because they're
they don't want to be vaccinated but
where there are people who are hesitant
and have requested they wanted a phone
call or a conversation with a clinician
so working really closely with ccg we've
identified the cohort of people so the
group of people who would benefit from
that phone call
um
and
what we're doing is supporting the
practices in terms of locum cover so
that the clinicians can have those phone
calls and then can support um can answer
the questions support the individual to
booking for a vaccination so these are
phone calls to people aged over 60 who
we would see as our most vulnerable who
who would really benefit from being
vaccinated who just are hesitant not
anti-vaxxers so that's a really exciting
program of work i think we've seen this
work previously i know that khan will
recall that we worked really hard with
voice of bme and they've been brilliant
in terms of doing this around cervical
screening and it was really powerful and
that conversation that individual
conversation does work and so it's
really thinking about
how we can prevent these people
either um
protect the um you know our most
vulnerable in the population and what
interventions we can put in place that
are evidence-based
interventions that we can evaluate so
that's one of them at the moment and um
just to say thank you to ccg colleagues
and jason bamford swift in particular
for supporting that program of work
so that's what we did last week it was a
busy week um but obviously i think
what's important to know is this none of
this has stopped this is very much still
being um implemented
um really looking and watching um
the rates on a daily basis and
recognizing that we're still much higher
than where we should be at the moment
the other bit that i wanted to talk to
you about is you'll have be aware that
there's been a huge amount of discussion
on the media around plan b
so at the moment there's been no no no
um kind of confirmation or no uh kind of
um
clarification as to whether plan b will
happen but i think what we need to be
mindful of in trafford is that we have a
huge number of very high um
footfall
kind of settings if you think about old
trafford the cricket ground
and the trafford center for example so
at the moment um
we are just thinking through what would
that mean locally and how would we plan
for that locally so nigel is going to
talk through um some aspects of that for
us as well
so thank you
thank you helen um
very comprehensive as usual he
questioned sir dorothy first and then
khan
yes i just wanted to say it's really
encouraging to see the rates going down
in the over 60s um but do we know why
that is and what the trend is there
um they haven't gone down that they're
stabilizing but it is just i think i
think the thing
not increasing it so they're kind of
they've increased over the last couple
of days but it looks like they're
steadying out which is really good um
i think with all the rates it's
important to just recognize the
volatility of it isn't it that we go up
and down quite a lot but i think it's
more about the trend rather than
the numbers so we're not sure why that
would be but um our data analysts are
watching those really carefully
so outbreaks and care homes for example
haven't increased so this will be
community so it might be grandma and
grandad or older relatives who um
have been looking after children perhaps
of school age for example but our
analysts do look at all the data at a
locality level to understand what's
going on
yeah what's the advice to people who
actually get covet who haven't been
tested they get covered and they want to
go on to have the vaccination how does a
question about how long they have to
wait some say it's 28 days some say 90
days
so it's 28 days for the vaccines if you
test positive then you can have the
vaccine after 28 days the 90 days is for
testing so if you've tested positive
the advice is not to have a pcr test for
90 days unless you're symptomatic so if
you develop symptoms and go and be
tested but the risk if you go and have a
pcr test when you're you don't have
symptoms then um
it the the risk there is that you'll be
picking up kind of some residual virus
so it may not be a true positive so it's
90 days for testing unless symptomatic
and 28 days data vaccine
thank you
thank you dorothy cohen
yes um
it may come later on the agenda but i'll
ask the question now
is to do with the children
from especially from schools
uh is there any correlation between
the
uh cases in schools transferring into
families
so that the
the the figures for the adults are
actually coming from the schools as well
i think that's really interesting
question khan and it's something that
we've looked at
um so we have seen um our analysts just
they do look at um
kind of the timelines with some of the
clusters of groups so we can understand
has it come from the chat is a child
tested positive first then mom and dad
on some occasions that is the case on
other occasions it's mom and dad testing
positive first
so i think it's it's a difficult one to
answer i think particularly with rates
in the community so high
um
but it is something that our analysts
look at very closely
thank you
councillor blackburn
okay uh thank you
thank you helen and uh it's a big
marathon this so thanks what you're
doing
i've got three questions um are schools
providing masks for children if the
family cannot afford to provide them
because obviously the master's all have
to be changed on a regular basis that's
my first question
helen you're on mute
hello we can't hear you
sorry my mute button keeps getting stuck
on today i don't know what's going on um
so i imagine this is something on a
school-by-school basis counselor
blackburn but we can find out for you
can ask the question um
but i should imagine the majority of
schools if children can't afford face
coverings we'll be providing them but we
can ask that question out to schools if
that would be helpful okay
and the second question is uh have we
got any delta variant a y point four
point two in the borough
so that obviously we're very much
watching um
variants of concerns and we do get
reports around variants of concern at
the moment we've not been notified of
any of those but it is something that we
do go back to ux which
was phe to ask the question of regularly
at this point we haven't been notified
and the last question is um
obviously our our residents have a lot
to do with the manchester residents
because you know we're so close to each
other and their their rates are you know
are a lot lower than ours are we
learning any lessons from maybe what
manchester doing
so that's a really interesting question
and it was one that was discussed at a
national meeting um recently so there's
an awful lot of
thinking around this is one is is there
an is is it due to
immunity so that community um was badly
hit in wave one and two the manchester
borders community in particular so do
they have a level of um
protection already that some of our
populations and if we think about the
spread in trafford
i think the feeling was that
the national meeting is actually
it was it started very much and still
remains um
[Music]
a virus of inequality so does impact the
hardest on our deprived communities
but due to what we've seen recently it
feels like it's flipped so at the moment
the the higher levels of activity
nationally are in more affluent areas
and it's you know it's just
understanding is that is because
um
this group were protected more in the
first and second waves potentially
you know if we think about how the
measures have changed in society at the
moment first and second waves we had all
the different measures in in kind of
community settings people worked from
home um
transport was you know really limited
whereas now um we don't have any of
those measures so
there is a feeling that perhaps those
people who are greater protected at the
beginning because of affluence are now
being
having more exposure to it and our
analyst team have looked at testing and
we are aware that in some of our
communities testing is lower so it's
just thinking through with our
manchester colleagues what the
difference is but again you know it's so
difficult to identify one particular
reason i think
okay thank you very much
thank you councillor blackburn are there
any further questions at all for helen
i don't see any thank you very much
helen so can we therefore move on to
mass testing with ben welcome ben
thanks chair
so a few updates today on testing
starting off um around some pc assessing
issues so as some of you may have heard
on the news there's been a recent issue
with people testing positive electro
flow test but then negative with a
confirmatory pcr test
we now know the reason for this which is
due to a pcr lab in wolverhampton giving
out around 43 000 negatives that were
actually positives so two key messages
we want to get out here is first of all
the ux which as hell says is the old
phase the uk health security agency
basically they've come out and said they
believe this is the only issue the only
lab that has this problem and therefore
that everyone should continue to go get
that confirmatory pcr test
and the second is that the key learning
obviously is that if you have a positive
test be electro flow or pcr then there
is a incredibly high chance that you do
have covered use the nature of the
specificity of how those those tests
work um if the situation doesn't happen
in traffic where we do get a positive
electric flow and negative pcr uh
contact tracing team will do that risk
assessment um for that case and provide
appropriate advice in that instance
yeah that's the key thing you want to
get across is that a continued to go get
a confirmatory pcr um and and the
chances are that
positive test will mean that you do have
kobe but if you have any questions you
can speak to our contact tracing team
that will provide that advice
um otherwise we have a new lateral flow
test being made available um this is
called mp bio so it's like the other
ones in many ways it's nasal only unlike
the others you need an adult to carry
out a test on a child below the age of
14 because most of them have that below
the age of 12. and when we've got more
details on this we'll let you know but
another key reminder as i mentioned the
other week always read the instructions
on those lecture flow tests because they
will be slightly different
um otherwise in terms of the work we've
been undertaking so we've continued to
do carry out testing and key settings
i've seen outbreaks and one setting we
tested in just after the last double
engagement board um two weeks ago saw a
huge number of positives identified
which shows the real value of doing case
finding when there's been now break
so i think the key thing from promote
today is just how crucial watch flow
testing can be and we know that around a
quarter of all positive cases are
identified through lecture flow tests um
and be either case finding as a result
of an outbreak or that regular twice
weekly testing it can be a really really
useful tool so um please encourage
everyone um to continue testing on a
regular basis with lots of flow tests
and obviously if you have any symptoms
doesn't matter how mild go get a pcr
and that's all from me chair
thank you any questions for ben
i don't see any ben at all so so thank
you and we can move on to the next item
which is contact tracing and outbreak
management and i welcome catherine
martland welcome catherine thank you
thank you councillor freeman good
morning everybody um so i'm just going
to give a little bit of an update today
on the outbreak and contact tracing hub
and the work that we've been undertaking
last week um so helen touched on some of
this but i'll run through the figures of
the education settings and the other
settings that we've been um working with
and also the contact tracing this week
and so we spoke to
um
10
schools last week as hella mentioned aim
for a risk assessment so
the the use of that is
to discuss with skills the measures that
they've got in place if we believe that
they may be in an outbreak situation so
it's a supportive conversation just to
um go over the things like the face
coverings hand hygiene aim good
ventilation in the classrooms
any social distance in one-way systems
things like that that they can put in
place in schools um the schools
continuously are working really really
well with those aims they're all
positive conversations
um we've had 414 case notifications last
week and we've also had a further 53
inquiries
um that we've that we've managed so
we've also worked with some schools on
risk assessments around things like
residential trips and clubs that they
run in the schools and again we've had a
really positive response from the
schools with that
with regards to other settings we've
received 14 case notifications
and we've had four inquiries and we've
also had 20 postcode coincidences that
we've looked into
um the third aspect of our role is the
local contact tracing so this is contact
tracing for any case positive cases in
trafford where the national team haven't
been able to make contact with them so
we followed up 394 cases last week and
we've had a really good contact rates we
managed to speak to 73 of those cases
and completed full contact tracing for
56 of those cases
and what we can also do with that is we
can identify residents in trafford who
might require extra support so we've
offered isolation support for 94 people
in addition to that last week
thank you
thank you very much catherine any
questions for catherine
at all
can i say i did see the social media
tweet today about isolation support uh
which has gone out so uh clearly i'm
very pleased that we're still offering
that um
i don't see any questions at all
counselor called any of you got a
question
no
no right well we'll move on then to uh
community uh to mass vaccination now
rebecca's center apologies i don't think
we've got anybody from ccg here
you still you're still on mute
are you chair it's fabiola here no i
don't think we've got any representative
from
the ccg we could ask an update from
rebecca perhaps circulated to all
members it would be useful because i
think there were probably going to be
questions asked about the booster
rollout
which
appears naturally to be quite slow
and uh and what the effects are in
trafford and also there were some
questions about um
walking centers being being available
for our 11 to 16 year olds which was the
national announcement yesterday helen do
you want to come in
so i've got some very basic information
i can share with you so obviously mft
are the lead for
our 12 to 15 year olds and
to date
10 schools have received the vaccine
the nurses are working exceptionally
hard um i think over 2 000 children in
trafford have received the vaccination
there was an there was a communication
which was um shared
from national around the potential for
walking centers and pcn so our primary
care networks to support that program of
work but i'm unclear as how that's being
implemented in trafford at the moment
but there is a huge amount of work
ongoing the booster
again
activity around that is happening and
all people eligible for the booster are
being asked to book
um and
ongoing work around ensuring
vaccinations that people who have
haven't had eligible people who haven't
had either vaccination or
still only have one dose are being
strongly encouraged to to um go and get
vaccinated at the moment
thank you thank you i know that we're
primarily concerned with kobe here but
coupled to this of course is the roll
out of the flu vaccination
which is relevant i think um in terms of
of the pressures it can put on
on
public health and the nhs i'll be any
further information on on the roll out
of
flu vaccine at all
you still look you're stuck on mute
again
oh god my mute button honestly sorry um
i couldn't comment in detail but my
understanding is flu campaign has
started in trafford people can access a
flu
vaccine
and people are encouraged to do so i'm
aware that it's already happening across
our schools so um
our intra health who provides school
vaccinations for flu are already out and
about vaccinating our children at the
moment so there's lots of activity
ongoing at the moment but unfortunately
i don't have the details sorry
that's fine thank you um got a question
from councillor blackburn
thank you yeah matt you mentioned about
the flu jab i've i've had my flu job
does there have to be a particular
period of time
before you can you're allowed to have
the boost step for the covid
my understanding is not but again we can
clarify that for you councillor
blackburn
and i have a further question from
councillor new gross
thank you um as part of us being
unfortunately number one in the country
last week i know two requests were made
to national um
for surge on both the booster program of
covid and for the flu vaccine can i ask
were they considered did we receive
anything
from that request
i'm afraid it'd be hard to be the ccg
that would be able to comment on that
i'm afraid councillor new gross
thank you
thank you uh okay then um
we'll move on then to community
engagement uh and nigel i know we were
going to do an extra piece of business
to do with the planning uh
or the preparations or for future plans
in relation to plan b do you want to
cover it all together with
with what's been going on in one go
yes i'm more than happy to yes that's
fine so in terms of the update from the
community engagement team um
so uh
given our high rates the team have uh
made an additional push on messaging to
um
all our kind of community contacts and
networks in each of the neighborhoods
over the last week so in particular
firstly promoting the vaccine uptake
including the various walk-in clinics
but also promoting
uh various cobra secure messaging with
the kind of wider call to action around
face covering social distancing hand
washing etc
uh the community hubs and local bcfc
have been supporting with cascading that
messaging as well as well as using our
community champions network and things
such as the friday prayers moss network
um
secondly in terms of the our youth
activity uh
the team have contacted 64
youth activity and sports centers across
trafford uh with kobit 19 good practice
messages to help keep attendees and
facilitators safe
uh we also
talk providing targeted support
to schools where required for example we
arrange translation of school materials
at a school where there are a large
number of parents
whose first language was not english so
just to help with that letter that was
mentioned earlier on that went out to
the school so we were able to translate
that
and also we linked in with the local
community partnership
to get the messaging out to surrounding
community via the local networks as well
um
we also supported um well are supporting
this week the pop-up clinics at the
traffic colleges so on monday there was
the one in
stratford and on thursday there's one in
uh in the south of the borough
um
we also been working on our autumn
winter plan so we had a big meeting last
week pulling all our plans together and
we're going to put all that on some
summary slides and a calendar of
activity which will be uh easy to share
with everybody so and share what we're
doing
this is going to focus on
covert safe messaging but also kind of
wider holistic health messaging
we're going to build in community
insight work into that working with
focus groups and we're also going to be
taking forward the public health
questionnaire work which we're starting
next week
so just a little bit more about that
questionnaire so
we're working with the public health
team on the vaccination questionnaire
which is um
aimed at those that are unvaccinated to
gain deeper insight into their reasons
and barriers to vaccination
and uh particularly in those areas where
we've seen low vaccine uptake so we've
developed a plan for the key
uh lsoa geographic areas with uh where
we're going to have in-person field work
which is going to start on the 26th of
october
through to the 16th of november
and we also plan to send out a digital
version of that questionnaire
as a citizen space link via gp practices
so
the previous pilot we did we spoke to
around 44 respondents excuse me
but with the work that we're doing now
in these different lso areas we've got
to go to eight areas
focused on um
you know key geographic areas where
we've seen lower uptake and we're
targeting around 30 people in each area
so with the aim of speaking to
you know at least 240 people over that
over that period of time
in terms of other community inside work
we're going to make contact with local
groups and organizations to co-host or
establish focus groups to try and get um
you know some understanding for people
in terms of the impact of covid over the
previous year current needs and concerns
and attitudes to risk
and to others
um and we're also going to adding to our
engagement work
trying to uncover reasons for any
issues around second dose hesitancy
among groups where the public health
team are seeing that this is a trend
and the last thing i just want to
mention was our community champions work
so we're looking at the moment around
the future remit of the community
around increasing numbers but also
potentially broadening the messages
which we're asking the champions to pass
on
and to kick that off we've organised a
briefing session with the champions uh
next week about two sessions actually
with the public health team a lunchtime
session and uh
evening session next week to catch up
with our champions
so that's an overview of the work from
the community engagement team uh before
i come on to plan b were there any
questions on that work
any questions at all
don't see any nigel oh sorry khan can't
please come here
thank you chair i just want to
echo what nigel has been talking about
and i think our experience is the same
that if you go and engage with the
communities the local people
you are likely to get more
response from them
but i think as a general point
um you can translate
uh leaflets in different languages which
we do
uh
but then you know when people receive
those those leaflets
uh they think they are just election
election leaflets
and uh
with due respect to all the counselors
uh many of the election leaders are not
ready by people they just put in the bin
we find that
video messages are
much more effective
and so we use them wherever necessary
and i think we put a lot of value on
video messages rather than just
translations
thank you
thank you
any further observations questions at
all
right nigel let's go with plan b
okay so for palm beach uh so uh nikola
talk with firm regulatory services give
me a note here to to talk through with
with you um
so essentially um
as i'm sure you're all aware the
government produced their autumn winter
plan which was published on the 14th of
september and they set out the
government's aims to sustain
the progress made and prepare the
country for future challenges
while ensuring that the nhs does not
come under sustained unsustainable
pressure during this period
so within the winter plan it states that
if the data suggests that the nhs is
likely to come under unsustainable
pressure then the government has
prepared what they call a plan b for
england
so just to clarify as helen said before
plan b has not been announced
uh but what will be used for just would
be just to give you a brief overview of
what is likely to be included in plan b
should it be announced and just um
a quick update on some of the initial
work which regulatory services are doing
on one aspect of this
so the government's plan b prioritizes
measures which can help control
transmission of the virus
while
seeking to minimize economic and social
impacts so it includes three main
parts
so the first thing suggested is
communicating clearly and urgently to
the public that the level of the risk
has increased and with it the need to
behave more cautiously
secondly introducing mandatory vaccine
only covets data certification in
certain settings
and thirdly legally mandating base
coverings in certain settings
so they're the three aspects but the
government have also said that they
would also consider asking people
once again to work from home if they can
for a limited period so that's the
fourth suggestion
so the one thing i just wanted to cover
in a little bit more detail was the
vaccine only
cobits data certification
so
i'm sure you're familiar familiar at the
moment with the nhs covid pass so the
government within the plan are
encouraging still the voluntary use of
the covid pass
and firstly has a tool to manage risk
but also to help prepare for any
mandatory introduction if that's
required but
with the
nhs kobit pass that um
provides uh individuals with
certification based on vaccination
testing or natural immunity
whereas with plan b uh if that is
implemented
the nhs kobe pass will change display
just for vaccination only so that's
that's the key point it's not about
whether you've been tested or the
natural immunity
however exemptions will continue to
apply for those who cannot be vaccinated
for medical reasons or for the under 18s
so
if this does come in the uh the um
the coping state association the vaccine
only one then
it's likely we're going to get um
very short notice on this so the
government expects the management of
accidentalistification could be
introduced um within
um just a week's notice so it could be
very short period
so what the government are thinking with
this is that
by introducing the vaccine only
certification it would allow settings
that have previously experienced long
periods of closure to remain open
and they believe that's preferable
obviously to closing venues entirely or
reimposing
capacity caps or social distancing
so this wouldn't apply to everywhere
it's going to
apply to
certain venues and events that's what
they're expecting so it would be the
kinds of venues that you would expect so
firstly all night clubs or other venues
open after 1am for alcohol music and
dancing
secondly indoor events with 500 or more
attendees where people are likely to
stand or mix into a significant number
such as music venues or large receptions
thirdly outdoor crowded settings with 4
000 or more attendees
um where they're likely to to stand or
move around during the event such as
outdoor festivals and finally settings
with 10 000 or more attendees such as
the large sports and music stadium so
that's what they're considering should
plan b be implemented
and as i said
should these measures come in place that
there could be very short notice and the
period could be as little as one week
so what i just wanted to mention from a
regulatory service point of view is that
because trafford is home to a number of
large supporting venues music venues and
conferencing facilities
because the notice period is so short um
the environmental health officers and
licenses team are taking a proactive
approach here
so firstly they've been working together
to identify premises within the borrower
who may fall under the scope of plan b
measures should they be introduced
and uh they're shortly going to be
contacting all these businesses to work
with them and make sure they have plans
in place
and so that hopefully if it plan b is
put in place it means there's minimal
impact to their business
so
that was the update from me chair but
happy to take any questions
uh thanks nigel um i mean if if plan b
is introduced and
the start to mandate face goblins
obviously be clearly gonna have to bring
back uh
the enforcement side back into this
meeting um the other thing is
you say it could happen within a week if
it's done so are we encouraging our
residents to download the nhs app which
shows your vaccine status
um which can be scanned uh i'm just
wondering you know what we could do to
encourage residents who haven't
downloaded and got the ability to
download the nhs app not the nhs track
and trace app by the nhs app which
actually does
uh show your vaccination status if this
if this comes in
um i'll throw it over to questions so
any questions at all
i don't see any so
does anyone want to comment on what i've
just said
yeah i think it's a really really good
idea
particularly when um as we've gone
through covid you've had a lot of people
who have been digitally excluded um so
raising awareness about the app i think
is going to be a good thing uh going
forward because i don't know where
everybody knows it's available um but
having said that um you've there are
ways of getting it by your gp through
the post so i think i think it's a very
good point that you raise
thanks to i mean
i use the app you can actually put
all your prescriptions on it you can
there's a whole lot that's carried your
medical records as well of course
um is there anything we can do around
this at all could the comms side at all
helen
hey council of three minutes ellie um
i'll just comment on that and just to be
clear um about what dorothy's just said
and people should not be asking their
gps um for the proof of their double
vaccination status it's not something um
that gp should be providing and it's
causing quite a big strain on primary
care and so when people go for their
second vaccination they're asking for it
and getting some more frustrated when
they can't provide it and there is a
website um where people can go and
actually order a printout so you can
there you could then carry um a printed
copy or you can ring 119 and ask for
that printed copy to be delivered so you
wouldn't actually need to access the
internet in order to get it and at the
moment nationally the nhs app itself has
not been promoted for that purpose but i
would assume that is because at the
moment there are very few um instances
in where people would need to prove the
double vaccination status other than
travel
um so it's not something that's been
done yet but it could be um it could be
something that we do um but as i say if
people need their own vaccination status
proving um then don't go to your gp um
either go online or ring 119
and can we do some some comms around
that than ellie just to let people work
locally so they're aware
please try and reduce the
um
you know the workload on gps for that
but we can do wider of course yes thank
you
uh khan question mike um
is it true that one could actually get a
qr code
for having had two vaccinations
absolutely
absolutely shows on you and if you've
got the nhs app you can go to kobe
passport and it shows you your qr code
now if you travel to france you've got
to show that and you've got to download
the french app to santikovic but you can
transfer it across
and um and it works very well i mean
it's just
it's just the accepted thing on the
abroad that you show your your your
vaccination status everywhere you go to
bars to restaurants to clubs
uh shopping malls and people just get on
with it and you know we seem to have
really in this country uh
missed missed an opportunity here
[Music]
um
i had a
an nhs card
where it
actually
tells you the
what date you were vaccinated for the
first and second one so
i don't know whether everybody receives
a card like that so that that's what i
did
you know
i just could just come in there
yeah um council accident that that's
what um people have been asking their
gps for and there is no sort of um legal
um status of that card because obviously
somebody could just get hold of a load
of empty cards and fill them in um so
people people feel reassured by carrying
one of those but in terms of you know if
anything was brought in um where you had
to prove that you had been double
vaccinated that card would have no um
it wouldn't carry any weight so um it is
important if people want to prove the
double vaccination status that they do
get um as counselor frame and says
either the app with their own personal
qr code on it or they actually ordered
their um certificate
right so there's no point in showing
that then to anybody
we don't have anybody to show at the
moment but uh
i think there's one gp said it's a
memento and nothing else really so yeah
well well it does actually tell you to
keep it and uh
you know put it in your wallet or
whatever first so yeah so i just thought
that everybody received that and it was
a statutory thing anyway
and and regarding anybody could
you know get a card like that and
i
um
i'd be surprised if you could but
um anyway
um
we have to go by the law anyway don't we
yeah
yeah
are there any further observations
questions at all on on nigel's input
thank you nigel it was uh comprehensive
let's let's hope we don't have to go to
plan b and i i did hear the business
secretary
uh on the radio this morning telling us
how well we're doing
um
so he says certainly we won't be going
for plan b but we'll wait and see we
never know might be next week the week
after
um
is there any further business this
morning at all i don't i haven't got any
notification of any
uh our next meeting is going to be on
the 3rd of november can i conclude by
thanking all of our public health staff
helen the whole team
the community engagement team for the
fantastic work that you're doing right
across trafford it's been a really
really tough last two weeks for you and
uh and you know just
thank you thank you very very much
indeed for the work that is going on uh
and i'm sure when we next time meet uh
our rates will be
much lower i'm looking at them yes last
night i'm predicting that rochdale the
way they're going up are going to go go
to the top of the list so there we are
thank you very much for your attendance